bonjour et bienvenue à la créance
montana et plus exactement à bella louis
avec cette jolie vue sur les montagnes
ou aujourd'hui j'aimerais vous
encourager à débattre je débattu des bas
nous débattons des bâtons tous ensemble
mais doit-on bien sûr aussi bien que
possible
alain aubut est remis alors petite
précision quand je dis de débattre jeudi
pas d'être frontale et de galles et en
provoquant les gens n'ont en fait ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est que ça serait
bien de mettre en pratique tout ce que
dont on parle ici dans cette série a
commencé à mettre en avant les raisons
pour lesquelles on débat et à réfléchir
à comment atteindre au mieux ses
objectifs que ce soit à travers de
discussions qu'on peut avoir dans des
situations publiques ou entre amis ou
entre familles ou sur internet sur
twitter sur youtube vous vous invite à
mettre en pratique ses idées de hashtag
des bâtons mieux car c'est bien beau la
théorie mais si on ne pratique pas en
vrai mais c'est un peu comme le ski on a
beau étudier la théorie c'est difficile
une fois qu'on est sur une paire de skis
si on n'a jamais pratiqué avant est
alors pour commencer je vous invite à un
peu choisir les gens avec qui
débattre parce que c'est difficile de
débattre avec tout le monde et je pense
qu'on a tous eu des expériences de débat
par exemple en famille qui ne se sont
pas toujours très bien passé
donc si l'on de commencer déjà avec les
débats le plus de chances de se bien se
passer
et si vous manquez de sujets de débats
avant de caresser déjà même jamais
vraiment ça qui manque
mais si jamais vous voulez un sujet de
débat original ou moins bas pourquoi pas
débattre de comment mieux débattre
particulier pour moi ça me ferait
vraiment vraiment beaucoup de bien
si d'autres personnes parler de comment
mieux débattre parce que parfois je dois
dire que j'ai l'impression d'être un
petit peu en mode monologue quand je
parle de débat tant mieux ça manque de
contribution de beaucoup de gens
différents moyennant et vous remercie
beaucoup ceux qui essaient de participer
à ce débat sur à cette réflexion
collective sur comment mieux débattre
mais j'aimerais que ça soit que faisait
plus beaucoup plus normalisé puis
surtout qui est des réflexions si
possible assez divergentes des miennes
parce que j'ai l'impression d'être
vraiment uniquement au tout début de ma
réflexion sur comment mieux débattre ça
fait vraiment seulement quelques mois
que je réfléchisse vraiment à ça et j'ai
l'impression d'avoir énormément
c'est un passant qui est une marque de
progrès énormes donc voilà s'il vous
plaît ne me laissait pas tout seul à
être le seul à défendre des idées pour
mieux débattre et donc vous pouvez
essayer d'engager ce genre de
discussions de réflexions collectives
dans la vraie vie mais vous pouvez
également le faire sur internet par
exemple sur twitter j'aimerais bien
avoir plus de tweets sur des réflexions
sur comment mieux débattre comme ça il y
en a quelques-uns et vous pouvez suivre
le hashtag achetés avec des bâtons mieux
pour 6 devoir de pas mal de réflexion
sur comment débattre mieux et twitter
comme vous le savez a ses limites et il
ya seulement 280 caractère par tweet on
peut faire des threads et quand c'est
long ça devient long essai par écrit et
beaucoup de gens préfèrent consommer à
l'information sous d'autres formes en
tout cas c'est mon cas notamment par
exemple en forme vidéo ou en format
audio est ce que je trouve
particulièrement bien avec le format
vidéo le format audio c'est que ça
permet de poser plus les choses de
prendre plus de temps d'avoir de
développer ses idées sans être
interrompu donc voilà si vous avez pas
mal de réflexion autour de comment mieux
débattre je vous invite à lancer votre
chaîne youtube ou votre podcast a juste
vous mettre en train de vous enregistrer
et techniquement il n'y a pas besoin de
moyens complètement fou je pense qu'un
téléphone d'aujourd'hui se chicanent pas
mal si vraiment vous voulez avoir un
truc d'une qualité potable et bien
acheté aussi un micro un micro cravate
comme l'a su que j'ai là qui coûtent 30
ou 40 euros
voilà pour vraiment pas cher on peut
largement lancé une chaîne youtube
aujourd'hui et avoir des réflexions
intéressantes par exemple autour d'eux
achetés avec des bâtons mieux et qui
sont en plus bien présenter parce que
mieux débattre c'est pas juste proposer
de meilleures idées
c'est également travaillé la forme dans
la menée avec laquelle ou présentée
telle ou telle idée est typiquement
travail et la forme d'une vidéo youtube
c'est quelque chose de très important
mais pour cela il n'y a pas besoin de
moyens en fout voilà encore une fois
matériel de base plus windows movie
maker ou ou à imovie pour ceux qui sont
sur mac ça suffit largement à faire un
truc déjà potable mais en ce qui me
concerne kg un bout préférentiels pour
les débats sous forme purement audio
donc j'aime bien écouter des podcasts et
c'est encore plus facile à faire un
suffit de le poser à nos micros quelque
part juste de parler
bon mais voir faire un peu d'édition
également audio mais un que voici vous
avez des discussions intéressantes
ça peut vraiment déjà valoir le coup est
en tout cas ça peut valoir le coup non
seulement pour vous non seulement pour
partager vos idées mais aussi pour vous
pour vous écouter en train de débattre
je trouve qu'il ya pas mal à apprendre à
juste photos écouter devoir tout se
conclut mal lorsqu'on faire un débat
c'est plus facile est auto critique
quand on s'entend débattre c'est assez
horrible en fait de se vendre par les
mois je obligé de percer en faut 2 mais
c'est comme un exercice et qui est à mon
sens très instructif en tout cas que tu
m'a été très instructif et d'ailleurs
bah je vais soumettre également ce
principe en pratique puisque j'ai décidé
de lancer un nouveau podcast
bon il y avait déjà assez longue
discussion avec thibaut de la chaîne
2000 se fie sur actions mais voilà ça
fait quand même plus d'un an et ses bras
montre écoulé beaucoup appris avec
travers ces discussions c'est toujours
très très sympa en tout cas moi j'adore
faire c'est possible de casque mais le
truc c'est que c'est toujours avec le
même gars qui est très fort en
philosophie mais disons que en géologie
ou en biologie il a un peu des points
faibles et malheureusement je suis
incapable de l'aider parce que je suis
encore plus mauvais que lui en tout cas
je pense qu'on est assez comparable au
niveau biologie et géologie 0 noël parce
que ce sont des sujets passionnants avec
beaucoup de choses à dire et notamment
par exemple sur les risques de pandémie
ou sur l'agriculture du futur assez
souvent ce sont des sujets passionnants
mais malheureusement on n'a pas vraiment
les bases pour vraiment aller loin dans
ses sujets et du coup ça m'a motivé à
lancer un autre podcast qui s'appelle
probablement et dont a priori un épisode
est peut-être déjà sortie peut-être pas
ça dépend du timing avec lequel je filme
tout ça mais a priori a déjà un épisode
qui est sorti qu'il ya une interview à
priori de l'hygiène mentale pour parler
un peu de zététique de sa perspective de
son background de sa vision des choses
et je trouve que c'est très intéressant
pour moi en tout cas je suis très
intrigués et très excité à l'idée de
faire le rôle de l'interviewer essayé
d'un d'année les gens a expliqué
clarifier leurs idées du mieux que
possible et un également aller titiller
pour essayer de voir les limites de leur
propre réflexion est également avoir
discussion sympa parce que ceci va être
honnête c'est aussi une occasion pour
moi de d'avoir un bon moment avec des
potes et ça je vous encourage également
à l'organiser alors pas forcément des
podcasts serait que c'est un peu
intimidant début même si je vous
encourage largement
faire des podcasts mais peut-être même
aussi à faire des groupes des
associations qui se réunissent
régulièrement et qui sait de débattre de
réfléchir plutôt collectivement autour
de sujets importants d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
c'est quelque chose qui déjà se met déjà
pas mal en place notamment à travers le
mouvement altruisme efficace quelque
chose que j'ai eu l'occasion de
participer à plusieurs de ses réflexions
collectives que ce soit à montréal à
paris à lausanne ou à genève
c'est toujours très très instructif et
c'est souvent là à chaque fois je sais
pas si c'est un accident
mais à chaque fois on a réussi à réunir
des gens qui étaient très très
intéressant et très très intéressés et
qui avait aussi des grands des très bons
réflexes de débats les débats que j'ai
eue au tour de ceux des mouvements à
très efficaces sont souvent les parmi
les débats les plus intéressants que
j'ai eu à la chance d'observer et auquel
j'ai eu la chance de participer
également à l'or il ya quelques groupes
d'altruisme efficace qui se sont montés
comme ça donc si vous êtes à genève ou
si vous êtes à lausanne
si vous êtes à zurich que vous êtes
autour de la sorbonne à paris il ya pas
mal de groupes de tourisme efficaces qui
sont déjà lancés il ya un groupe très
efficace qui est en train de se lancer à
l'école polytechnique
alors si je me trompe pas lorsque cette
vidéo sortira le groupe sera déjà lancé
école polytechnique et je sais également
qu'à centrale supélec qu'ils ont monté
un groupe de discussion autour des
problèmes d'éthique d'une intelligence
artificielle
donc je vous invite voilà si vous êtes
dans une université ou dans une
entreprise également eu l'occasion de
participer à des discussions de groupe
de travail là qui sont liées un peu à
des entreprises qui sont un peu d'aidé
meetup notamment où il ya des
discussions très intéressantes qui
peuvent aller plus loin et qui peuvent
poser le débat par exemple sur le plan
de l'éthique désire donc si vous êtes
dans une entreprise ou dans une
université
ce qui est probablement le cas j'imagine
voilà c'est peut-être une bonne idée
d'essayer de monter ce genre de groupes
de discussions de réflexions autour des
grands sujets importants de demain est
déjà d'aujourd'hui voilà si vous avez
peu s'il vous manque des sujets ne les
bat allez faire un tour sur it's gonna
wars ou sur le site et d'altruisme
efficace france ou sur mes vidéos ou sur
les vidéos de thibault ou sur les vidéos
de réveillère sur le changement
climatique ou sur les vidéos de d'esprit
critique d'hygiène mentale
énormément de sujets à aborder mais
l'idée c'est patent d'arriver à une
solution finale c'est déjà d'instaurer
un climat de débats et de s'habituer à
débattre et si possible de bien débattre
sur des sujets qui sont importants ils
pas sur les sujets classiques le dire de
l'actualité qui sont pas forcément les
sujets les plus importants pour demain
on va dire donc voilà j'espère que vous
allez vous mettre vous aussi à débattre
peut-être davantage et surtout à
réfléchir à comment mieux débattre au
moment de débattre davantage pour que on
est tous plus de bons réflexes au moment
où on est choqué par telle ou telle
information et qu'on a envie de réagir
de façon instantanée et souvent on
réagit très très mal c'est important de
développer ses réflexes et pour cela
c'est important juste de débattre
règlement en favorisant en encourageant
les bons réflexes donc j'espère que vous
allez faire ça et vous peut commencer à
faire ça dès à présent comme tout joueur
dans les commentaires de cette vidéo 5
sur rolle alors que je fais un petit 360
avant de vous abandonner